Sind wir in einer Praxis oder im Krankenhaus?
Egal, das ist ihr Wort.
Okay.
Wir sind in einer Notaufnahme, im Krankenhaus.
Okay, ja.
Guten Abend.
Mein Name ist Kent.
Ich bin desustand gestern auf der Notaufnahme.
Bevor wir mit dem Analysegespräch anfangen, möchte ich Ihre Personalidad aufnehmen.
Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Aber natürlich. Guten Abend.
Frau Dr. Wie war das? Dr. Genc.
Ja, mein Name ist Genc.
Ah, das klingt so türkisch. Kommen Sie aus der Türkei?
Ja, Sie haben recht. Ich komme aus der Türkei.
Das ist toll. Ich komme auch aus der Türkei.
Ach so. Wirklich.
Wir können weiter machen.
Wir können auch Deutsch weiter machen.
Okay.
Mein Deutsch ist nicht so gut, Frau Dr.
Deswegen.
Ich versuche.
Wenn Sie Schwierigkeiten hätten, können wir einfach wechseln.
Ja.
Okay.
Also, mein Name ist Frau Mazes.
Gut.
Können Sie Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen buchstabieren?
Mazes, Martha, Anton, Zeppelin, Emil, Zeppelin.
Okay.
Und Nachname ist Kurt, K-U-R-T.
Frau Kurt, oder?
Okay.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 67 Jahre alt.
67 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie geworden?
Am 25. April 1956.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 1 Meter, ich glaube 68.
68.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Oh, zu viel, Frau Doktor.
Zu viel. Ich habe wieder Gewicht zugenommen.
Ich glaube, im Moment habe ich 85 Kilo.
85.
Okay. Vielen Dank für die Informationen.
Jetzt können wir über Ihre aktuelle Wichtwörter sprechen.
Was führt Sie heute zu mir?
Frau Doktor, ich habe seit circa 3 Wochen Schmerzen an der Seite.
Am Rücken.
Rechts und Seite.
Auf der rechten Seite, genau an der Wirbelsäule oder in der Nähe.
Der Wirbelsäule.
Starkes Schmerzen, das sticht richtig rein.
Jedes Mal wenn ich versuche, einzuatmen,
dann bekomme ich so einen richtigen Schmerz wie ein Messerstich.
Also stichende Schmerzen haben Sie?
Ja, ja, ja. Und es wird nicht besser.
Obwohl ich schon so viele Schmerz-Tabletten genommen habe,
hört es nicht auf.
Was haben Sie eingenommen?
Das war Ibuprofen, 800.
Das 3-4 Mal am Tag.
Okay.
Seit 3 Wochen nehmen Sie regelmäßig jeden Tag?
Ja, ich nehme jeden Tag mindestens 2-800, manchmal sogar 3.
Aber das wird nicht besser.
Es gibt keine Wirkung.
Nein.
Nur ganz für ein paar Stunden vielleicht.
Und haben Sie rötliche Flicken bemerkt auf der Seite, auf der Haut?
Nein, habe ich jetzt nicht gesehen. Nein.
Okay.
Ich habe im Spiegel geschaut, aber das sieht alles normal aus.
Keine Bläschen haben Sie bemerkt? Nein, habe ich nicht gesehen. Nein.
Und sind die Schmerzen im Laufe der Zeit schlimmer geworden?
Oder sind Sie immer gleich als Intensität, meine ich?
Ich würde sagen, Sie haben sich ein bisschen verschlechtert.
Ja, ich würde sagen, Sie haben sich ein bisschen verschlechtert.
Wie würden Sie die Schmerzen einschätzen auf eine Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10?
1 ist sehr leicht und 10 sehr stark schmerzen.
Als im Moment würde ich sagen, das hat mit 3-4 angefangen, würde ich sagen.
Und ist jetzt vielleicht bei 6-7?
6-7, okay. Sie haben zugenommen.
Also, okay.
Haben Sie weitere Beschwerde bis auf diese Schmerzen?
Ja, also wie gesagt, ich bekomme manchmal schlecht Luft deswegen.
Ich muss vielleicht dazu sagen, ich habe auch eine chronische Bronchitis, eine COPD.
Ich bin eher Resprays.
Und ich habe den Eindruck, dass diese Bronchitis auch schlechter geworden ist seit 2-3 Monaten.
Ja.
Vielleicht ist es eine Bronchitis.
Sie haben ja Luftnot seit 2-3 Monaten.
Keine richtige Luftnot, aber es ist schlechter geworden als vorher.
Was nehmen Sie regelmäßig gegen COPD?
Da habe ich noch 2 Sprays.
Das ist eins mit so einem blauen Deckel.
Ich glaube, das heißt Salbutamol.
Salbutamol, ja.
Und dann habe ich noch eins, das hat so einen grünen Deckel.
Ich glaube, das heißt Peridual oder so ähnlich.
Peridual.
Peridual, ja.
Erinnern Sie sich an die Dosierungen?
Oh, nee, das weiß ich leider nicht.
Sie machen jeden Tag 1 Hübe, oder?
Ja, ich nehme jeden Tag von beiden 2 Hübe morgens.
2, okay.
Aber Sie haben gemerkt, dass es eine Verschlechterung gibt mit COPD?
Ja, das ist von meinem Eindruck, normalerweise haben diese Sprays immer ganz gut geholfen.
Aber jetzt seit 3 Monaten, denke ich, ist es nicht so gut.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen?
Auf der Brust habe ich keine Schmerzen.
Sie haben nur auf der rechten Seite und in den Mund.
Sehr punktuell.
Da ist eine ganz kleine Stelle, wenn man da mit der Hand hinkommt, dann tut es besser.
Haben Sie etwas Schweres gehoben vor 3 Wochen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Nichts?
Nein.
Machen Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Nein, ich mache keinen Sport.
Haben Sie Fieber, Stuhlfrost?
Nein, nein, Fieber habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein, da habe ich nichts.
Mit dem Wasserlassen ist das schon länger so.
Meine Frau ärztin sagt, die Blase ist etwas schwach geworden.
Wenn ich mal huste, dann läuft es ein bisschen raus.
Aber sonst habe ich keine Probleme.
Haben Sie Schlafprobleme?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Sie können gut schlafen in der Nacht, trotz COPD.
Ich werde wegen den Schmerzen immer wieder wach, weil wenn ich mich drehe,
oder auf die Seite lege, dann kann ich mich gar nicht hinlegen.
Dann tut es viel, dann muss ich mich auf die andere Seite drehen.
Ich werde manchmal auch in der Nacht wach.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Nein.
Jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Vorgeschichte einige Frage stellen.
Haben Sie schon gesagt, Sie leiden an COPD seit wieviel Jahren?
Seit ungefähr 15 Jahren.
Haben Sie noch weitere Erkrankungen?
Ich habe Medikamente für den Blutdruck.
Ja, seit wann?
Seit 20 Jahren.
Ich habe Medikamente für Allergien, für den Frühjahr,
damit die COPD nicht schlechter wird.
Seit zwei Jahren habe ich Medikamente für den Diabetes.
Was nehmen Sie gegen Blutdruck und Diabetes?
Ich kann mir das nicht merken, Frau Doktor.
Ich habe Kandisatan, 16 mg, eine morgens, eine abends.
Dann habe ich Atorvastatin, 40 mg, das ist für das Cholesterin.
Ich habe mir meinen Arzt aufgeschrieben.
Ich nehme eine am Abend.
Ich habe Ihnen schon gesagt.
Was setzen Sie für eine Milligrammschuldigung?
Bitte? 40.
40.
Danke schön.
Was habe ich noch gesagt?
Diabetes gegen Diabetes.
Für den Diabetes nehme ich seit Neuestem,
ich hatte vorher Med-for-Mean.
Das habe ich nicht so gut vertragen,
da habe ich immer Durchwelle bekommen.
Ich habe 10 mg, eine am Morgen.
Sie sind zu viel Medikamente.
Ich muss sie alle einnehmen.
Haben Sie allergingegen Heuschnupfen?
Ja, gegen Polen und Gräser.
Ist das sehr saisonär?
Ja, nur im Frühjahr, dann für ein paar Monate.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja.
Seit wann?
Seit 50 Jahren.
Wie viele Zignette am Tag?
Ich habe es ein bisschen reduziert.
Ich habe immer eine Schachtel ungefähr geraucht,
aber jetzt mache ich ungefähr 10 Zigaretten am Tag.
Eine halbe Packung am Tag.
Seit wann haben Sie diese reduziert?
Seit zwei Jahren.
Das ist sehr gut.
Wegen COPD haben Sie das gemacht?
Ja.
Okay, das haben Sie gut gemacht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, ich trinke keine Alkohol.
Okay.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Früher habe ich gerne etwas Rakie getrunken,
aber das mache ich jetzt auch nicht mehr.
Okay.
Aber nicht mehr.
Momentan trinken Sie.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Lust?
Momentan.
Ich habe ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer aktuelle Wäsche.
Deswegen bin ich nicht zurück.
Ja, also immer wieder.
Denn Russen habe ich schon immer wegen der COPD.
Am meisten morgens.
Weißens morgens und manchmal auch am Tag.
Trotz der Medikation bekommen Sie immer noch erstens morgens.
Ja, ja.
Aber das ist üblich für Sie.
Es ist nicht geändert in den letzten drei Wochen.
Es ist halt das Gefühl,
dass tagsüber die Luft etwas schlechter ist als vorher.
Wenn Sie einatmen, nehmen die Schmerzen zu?
Ja, wenn ich eine atme oder mich bewege,
dann sticht es wie ein Messer an dieser eine Stelle rein.
Okay.
Haben Sie beim Husten ausruf?
Nein.
Nein, kein ausruf.
Ich muss kurz gucken, ob ich alles richtig aufgeschrieben habe.
Ja.
Sind die Schmerzen still und schmerzen?
Und keine Ausstrahlung, oder?
Nein.
Nur auf einige Punkte.
Ja, Frau Kurt, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, ich würde mich freuen,
wenn Sie sagen können, was es ist und ob Sie mir andere Schmerzstabote geben können.
Weil das hört nicht auf.
Und so langsam mache ich mir Sorgen.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie.
Ich glaube, haben Sie eine Bauch-Grußpfählentzündung?
Und diese Diagnose zu bestätigen,
dass ich eine Röntgenaufnahme durchführen lassen.
Und ich nehme Ihnen Blut ab, damit wir im Blut Entzündung Zeichen sehen können.
Und ich werde Sie natürlich körperlich unter Suchung die Lunge abhören.
Und damit können wir die Situation oder den aktuellen Zustand vom COPD sehen.
Und dann gibt es eine Veränderung in der Lunge.
Okay, das hört sich gut an.
Gut. Machen Sie das alles heute noch?
Ja, wir machen alles heute.
Weil das ich wichtig finde.
Ja, und dann müssen wir sofort behandeln.
Okay, gut.
Gut, danke.
Ich tatus familien, sozialen Nese ist halt.
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Hat die Patientin ein Trauma gestürzt, ist sie hingefallen?
Ja.
Hat sie etwas angestoßen worden?
Nur eine Frage gestartet, können Sie geholen?
Haben Sie etwas Schwieres geholen, aber das genügt nicht.
Eine Trauma sollte ich nachfragen, ja.
Warum?
Woran denken Sie, weil Trauma oder Sturz?
Es könnte vielleicht ein, das ist schon eine alte Frau,
vielleicht ein Rippenfraktur.
Ja, das wäre eine Möglichkeit.
Vielleicht Osteuroporose.
Also da müssen wir gleich mal die Ergebnisse, Sie haben Labo und
umgemacht, keine Erbündungszeichen.
Blutbildweise rote Blutblutblötchen sind sehr gut.
Schilddrüsenwerte sind gut.
Nierenwerte sind gut.
Leberwerte sind gut.
Alles unauffällig.
Nur der Zuckerwert des Hemoglobin A1c ist bei 6,7.
Ja, leicht erhöht.
Diabetes hat Blutdruck 130 zu 70.
Beim Abhören auf die Lunge hören Sie nur beidseites Basal,
leichtes Knistern und ein bisschen feuchte Rasselgeräusche
im Rahmen der COPD.
Knistern habe ich nicht verstanden.
Ein Entfaltungsknistern, wenn man tief atmet.
Wenn Sie Papier, Sie werden schüttelt.
Wir sagen auf Türkische Reputation, oder?
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht, was es auf Türkisch ist.
Nicht Türkisch, ateinisch, Reputation.
Reputation, genau richtig.
Knistern, das ist das Knistern.
Sie hat eine Röntgenaufnahme bekommen.
Jetzt vielleicht zur Information.
Sie haben die Körper nicht untersucht.
Sie fassen die Patientin an von außen.
Sie hat Paraveterbral rechts.
In Höhe der 8en Rippe, wenn Sie auf die Rippe drücken,
auf diese eine Stelle höllische Schmerzen.
Sehr starke Schmerzen.
Stechend.
Auf der rechten Seite, auf der rechten Seite.
Sonst hat sie keine Schmerzen.
Sie machen eine Röntgenaufnahme.
Sie sehen einen Lungenemphyseem bei COPD.
Sie sehen auf der linken Seite ganz schwache,
weise Punkte anzuflecken.
Linken Seite, auf der linken Seite.
Auf der linken Seite.
Nein, eben oberen Lungenlappen.
Oberen Lungenlappen, weise Flecken.
Affekt, genau.
Was machen Sie weitere Untersuchungen?
Vielleicht könnte es eine, aber Sie hat keine...
Was machen Sie für weitere Untersuchungen?
CT-Torax.
Im CT-Torax kommt raus.
Sie hat an der 8en Rippe eine Rippenfraktur.
Ohne Trauma.
Sie hat Raumförderungen.
Flecken auf der linken Oberlappen.
Und sie hat einen kleinen Knoten an der linken Brust.
Circa 2 cm in 3 Uhr.
Mama Zäa und Metastasierung.
Jetzt habe ich es vorhin praten.
Und jetzt bekommt diese Patientin, hat eine Mammografie bekommen sofort.
Sie hat diesen 2 cm großen Knoten.
Und was machen wir jetzt mit der Brust?
Ein Nadelbiopsy.
Eine Biopsy, eine Stanzbiopsy.
Das bekommt Sie jetzt morgen, glaube ich, bei uns.
Genau.
Und jetzt kommt das
und wird es morgen bei uns.
Sehr gut.
Jetzt habe ich vorher schon verraten.
Jetzt machen wir Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch.
Okay.
Ich fange an.
Guten Abend, Herr Obaz.
Heute möchte ich Ihnen eine neue Patientin vorstellen.
Sie ist Frau Kurt.
Sie ist 67 Jahre alt.
Sie berichtet über seit 3 Wochen bestehenden Rückenschmerzen
auf der rechten Seite.
Die Schmerzen sind im Laufe der Zeit verschlimmert.
Am Anfang war die Interest bei 4 von 10.
Aber momentan ist es 6 von 10.
Sie hat keine Bläschen bemerkt.
Die Haut ist intakt.
Die Schmerzen sind stechend.
Sehr pünktlich.
Auf mehrere Punkte kann sie die Schmerzen spüren.
Sie leidet an COPD schon seit 15 Jahren.
Aber seit 2-3 Monaten hat sie eine Verschlechterung bemerkt.
Momentan hat sie Husten wie immer.
Sie hat keine Vegetative-Anamnese.
Sie ist unaufwählig bis auf Urin in Kontinenz beim Druck.
Sie leidet an folgende Erkrankungen.
Arterielechipatinue seit 20 Jahren.
Sie wird mit Kandisat an 16 mg morgens Abend behandelt.
Sie leidet an seit 2 Jahren Diabetes-Militus.
Sie behandelt mit Faxiga 10 mg.
Sie hat Saisonalalagi.
Dafür bekommt sie Sprich im Frühjahr.
Die COPD ist mit Salbutamol und Peridualsprich behandelt.
Sie nimmt auch Atomastatin 40 mg abends ein.
Ich habe leider Familien- und Sozell-Anamnese vergessen zu fragen.
Sie sehen die Patienten später noch mal.
Dann frage ich.
Sie ist starke Raucherin.
Sie ist 50 Jahre alt.
Sie hat ungefähr 1 Schacht pro Tag.
Seit 2 Jahren hat sie reduziert.
Aber sie hat ungefähr 50 Packungen.
Sie trinkt kein Drogen und kein Alkohol.
Sie hat die Annamnistische Angaben am 1. Sprechen.
Sie hat eine Rippenfragtur.
Sie hat noch ein Traum?
Vor 3 Wochen hatte sie eine Trauma.
Die Patientin ist nicht gestürzt und hat kein Trauma.
Sie hat eine Diagnose.
Die Diagnose könnte folgende Erkrankungen kommen.
Sie haben jetzt die Untersuchungen und die Ergebnisse.
Sie haben die.
Ich habe Röntgenaufnahme gemacht.
Da habe ich eine Rippenfragtur auf der 8. Rippen gesehen.
Auf der linken Apex der Lunge habe ich ein weiße Flecke.
Im Oberlappen habe ich eine Verschaltung gesehen.
Ich wollte noch ein CT-Torax veranlassen.
Bei CT-Torax habe ich eine Raumforderung gesehen.
Und noch im linken Brust.
Der Raumforderung ist mit Oberlappen in der linke Lunge.
Und in der Brust auch.
Ein Zentimeter, noch eine Raumforderung habe ich gesehen.
Dann haben wir eine Konsulbeten von Genokologen.
Oder eine Nadelbiopsy durchführen zu lassen.
Woran denken Sie jetzt?
Erst mal hätte sie eine Mamazea.
Oder Bronchialcasinone.
Das ist eine Metastasierung in Oberlappen.
Dann würde man sagen, mit der Rippenfragtur.
Das ist wahrscheinlich eine Oseapulmonal metastasiertes Mamakarsinomling.
Das ist der Verdacht jetzt.
Sie hat keinen Trauma, keinen Sturz, keine Verletzungen.
Sie hat eine Rippenfragtur.
Das bricht nicht so schnell.
Das ist eine metastasenbedingte Fraktur.
Allein reicht es schon leicht zu husten.
Dann muss man mit dem Bild denken,
dass man einen hochgradigen Verdacht auf ein Oseapulmonal metastasiertes Mamakarsinomling hat.
Hier veranlassen wir weitere Untersuchungen.
Ein Knochenzintigramm, ein Abdomensonogramm.
Wir müssen schauen, ob auch eine Leberfilie,
eine Lebermetastasen verurlegen oder ob im Knochen-Skeletz-System,
andere Knochenzintigraphie, ob andere Bereiche befallen sind.
Natürlich eine Standspüropsi.
Die gibt uns dann ein Bericht oder ein Aufschluss.
Die Metastasierung wäre auch wichtig.
Ich fand das ein sehr interessantes Bild.
Die Patientin, die Mutter, kommt mit ihrer Tochter und sagt,
sie hat so Rippenschmerzen.
Man denkt, pluritis, vielleicht prunkitis.
Aber ich hatte ein komisches Gefühl,
als die Patientin sagte, sie hatte es seit drei Wochen.
Es war nichts vorgefallen.
Meine erste Frage war, bist du hingefallen oder gestürzt?
Alte Frauen stürzen immer wieder.
Sie sagte, nein.
Ich wollte dann kein Röntgen, ich wollte sofort ein CT.
Ich habe sofort ein CT veranlasst,
und da hat man das sofort gesehen.
Jetzt ist die Tochter sehr traurig.
Die Mutter sagt, ich bin schon sehr alt, kein Problem.
Danke.